The Joe Rogan experience. So when,
when you first start rapping, like, uh,
you wrap them with kids in
your neighborhood or you
like aspiring to be a rapper
and, right and shut down and
try and things on your friends,
like how do you get started? Well, the way
that I started, I was writing, you know,
like poetry first. Really? Yeah. But
what kind of poetry? Just like, you know,
like hoods, stuff, you know,
just stuff that rhymed, but like,
just sort of writing it down. Like it
was a, it was almost like writing raps,
but it just,
you know,
it's without saying it right is you
read it and shit like that, whatever.
But I would just write poetry
about, you know, everyday shit.
You know what I mean? Nothing, you
know, it wasn't like doing like the,
I dunno if there's like categories
of poetry, but it, you know,
it was just stuff that, that would
happen from day to day, you know. And uh,
I had a knack for writing. I realize
that now is wanting to be a journalist.
That's,
you know what really the
thing that I thought I was
going to be at school. Right.
Do you right now, uh, I
was for a while, but I,
I looked at kind of stuff just again,
everyday stuff or you know,
I'd like randomly pick
something to write about.
So if it was Ken about the cannabis
industry, I'd write something about that.
If it was about the music industry,
I'd write something about that. Like I,
that every now and then I
would, uh, there was, uh,
back in the early two thousands,
there was a magazine called
industry insider magazine.
And occasionally I would
write articles for that.
I wasn't really that great because, you
know, I was so spotty in school that,
you know, my, you know,
it needed work, you know,
but they left it raw the way that,
that I would put it out there and people
got my point and that, that was cool.
But I looked at it, uh,
in the way that the,
the music that I've done in a lot of
the songs serve as a certain form of
journalists, journalism for
me, you know, like, you know,
bringing up certain issues that
people don't necessarily hear.
Like throw your set in the air
as a song on temple's boom.
And it's a song about how you would get,
you know,
in inducted into again,
how you get put into a gang,
how you fall into it. And some
people might think, you know,
by hearing it that it was glorifying
it and praising it, but it wasn't,
it was basically this is how
it is. This is so, you know,
the signs to look for if your kids are,
you know,
fucking around with the wrong people,
you know? And that's, you know,
I took it like, okay, you know, maybe I'm
not a journalist like I intended to be,
but this is my way of it.
You know,
I can enlighten people with certain
things and uh, you know, like anything,
somebody's going to read something or
hear something and maybe misinterpret what
you say.
But you know,
it's all about who's who's listening
and who's reading and who's watching and
stuff like that and their interpretation
of it. And some get it, some don't.
And that's just the nature of it. But
like most people get it. And I've,
I've come across people that have
come to me and come and said,
hey man, your your, your songs on
temple of boom men. You know, they,
they help to get me through these
times or these songs raised me,
they taught me this, this and
that. That's awesome. And to
me, you know, that, that's,
that's the impact right there. That's
the shit that means more than anything.
Because I'm sure you remember songs that
got you through, right? Oh yeah, for sure.
You know, there was songs from Krs
one public enemy that, you know,
got me through and fired me up, you
know, and inspired and stuff like that.
Era's ones. Another one people
forget about, man, I'll be
in my car. Just gone. Ooh,
that's nice. Yeah. I mean he, he taught,
he taught me how to be a bull horn, you
know what I mean? Like tell you know,
like yeah, tell the truth, you know,
yours get the word out and, and,
and not be fearful of what might happen
because he could have been one of the
biggest stars in, in hip
hop. He chose not to be,
he chose to be a voice. And sometimes
in being that voice, you know,
you get objects put in front of you
and uh, certain opportunities don't,
you know, get put on your table
because he says some great shit, man.
He's talking about getting
mad at the president.
It's like being mad at the manager
at McDonald's. Yeah. You know,
for the way the corporations
being run. Yeah. It's, it's, he,
he is a very insightful in,
in the shit that he says and he is
very unafraid to state it in state.
His opinion,
if for you to get like people coming up
to you when they first started coming up
to you, telling you that your
music got them through things,
that it means so much to them
when that first started happening,
that must've been surreal, you know?
Yeah, it could because as a artist,
as especially as a young artist you,
that's not something you think about.
All of these songs are going to,
well it depends on,
on the artist you are right guys hit.
How old were you?
Like 23 or something like that.
And how old were you when that was like a,
we released in 91 and it really started
going for us in [inaudible] 90 2022 kid.
He had so crazy there goes the baby fro.
Wow.
Wow. Look at the baby fro. Yeah,
but I mean think about that man.
That is so crazy for you to go
from the guy who yo MTV raps.
Who remembers that?
I did a bungee jump at this spring break
with a trench from naughty by nature.
Was that the one that was in Cancun? None
of that was Daytona beach right there.
Okay. When MTV was still, when
MTV was still allowed over there,
it was back when MTV had music.
Yeah.
When they had music format
empty was MTV was music videos.
Yeah. Good luck finding a
fucking music video now.
They still got to go to youtube.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Wow.
That's wild.
What was it like when it first started
popping off and you were 22 years old?
Was it, did it feel real? It was a,
it was a crazy thing because it's not
something that I had ever envisioned
happening. You know, I
didn't think that, you know,
the music would blow up like that,
you know,
we were doing it to obviously try
and make a name for ourselves and,
and uh, make music that people like, but
fuck, we didn't see that coming at all,
especially with insane in the
brain when they told me, uh,
when like when killer man started going,
it was like surreal because, you know,
we didn't think that song would
take, just because you know, of,
of the chorus itself, you know, fuck
what the song is about. You know,
we knew that the chorus was,
you know what,
they were going to hear more
than anything. And so I, you
know, we, we thought, Nah,
we're going to have a good underground
album. We didn't realize it would blow up.
We didn't think they were going to put
killer man in the juice movie and that
would blow that song up even more
so than it was it was getting, um,
because we had released funky feelings
ones first and it was a double Aa side,
single funky filling and kill a man
on the other side, which means, um,
at that time that Dj's had the option
of which song they wanted to go.
Whereas most of the time you had a side
B side and the a side is most definitely
the one that the record
company wants you to push.
We gave it a Aa side because we thought
maybe the djs would like kill a man
more.
They went with funky fill when the record
company because they figured it would
be easier to market.
Right.
And then the DJ started flipping the
record course and we started getting
traction behind that.
Our record was out,
like six months had dropped off
the chart and they flip the record.
Our shit slowly starts
to go back up the chart.
We got back on the chart
and started climbing and we
were getting a whole lot of
mixed show play.
And uh,
then we started doing a lot of
promotional shows that being one of them.
And it started going and kill a man.
Started getting us going. And uh,
I mean we toured for
probably a year and a half,
like a lot of just a lot of promotional
shows, you know, not getting paid,
you know, just, you know,
Sony having us out there promoting the
record and by the time, uh, you know,
our record got back back up into
the middle of the charts. I mean,
it was still rising and they saw that.
They're like,
we got to get them off the
road and making a new record.
So that's when we got up there with
black Sunday and a with black Sunday and
insane coming out again.
That's not a song I thought would blow up
when they've chose that for the single.
I'm like, well, all right, there's better
songs but fuck it. That's the one. Okay.
So it comes out, boom, it explodes.
And now we have our black Sunday
charting it, number one coming in.
And our,
our first album had come all the way
from the bottom to hit number five.
So we had to two albums in the top 10
to hunt or top 10 of the 200 songs,
you know, on the chart, which no
one had ever done in hip hop before.
We had one in five slot.
And uh, you know, fuck,
we definitely didn't think that was
going to happen. I mean, you know,
it was all a surprise and it went from
one minute you could go to a mall and be,
you know, an assuming and nobody even
knows who the fuck you are and you know,
you're getting about your day to now
you go to the mall and the whole fucking
mall is swarming on you. Like
fucking, you're like, you know,
Paul Mccartney or something.
It was the craziest shit. They,
they would ask us to leave the mall's
like, really? Yeah. Like, uh, we used to,
I used to go to this one called the
Montebello Mo. It was in Montebello.
I can't remember what the name of the
mall was, but it was in Montebello,
the only one down there at the time.
And we knew everybody there,
you know, as we're coming up because
that's where we'd go shop. So, you know,
you make friends and people in the
shop and stuff like that. And uh,
when we come back off the tour this
time and go try to go to that mall,
you know, one of our friends fucked
up in war Cypress Hill jacket. Oh,
and that's like a fucking billboard
when you're standing next to one of us.
Right. So before you know it, boom,
we get swooped in and you know,
as a pre cell phone too. Yeah. In the
mall security. Cause I, Hey man, you know,
I know it's fucked up.
You guys got to go
really? Like, yeah man, it's a commotion.
You guys gotta go, they're telling me,
I'm like, they think someone's going
to fight. I'm like, wow. All right.
I never went back to that mall after
that. I was like, all right, cool.
Because you know what,
I didn't want to cause them problems too.
It was now it was tough to go
somewhere at that time and not get,
you know, swarmed and get swarmed.
Yeah. It was, it was, uh, it was quite,
quite, uh, an experienced
man like, you know,
cause you only ever hear about it until
it happens and you might, you know,
if you have friends in the industry
and it's happening for them,
you might see it in directly, you know,
like through the, through their shit.
And uh, you know, we had friends in
the business, you know, for cred.
Kid for us was one of my friends,
um,
before we got out there and cause
he's still around. Yeah. Yeah.
He still does stuff, you know. Um,
I don't know if he's putting out
so much new music these days,
but he's still here and there.
He's doing some of the
cannabis industry stuff too,
because he is a big kind of sore.
I've got to tell you,
my man smokes used to smoke
like a train man, like him.
And I would trade joints off left and
right, but you know, for a time, you know,
I would go hang with him and his gigs,
I'd be his bodyguard cause I was the one
that was not afraid to carry the hammer,
meaning the magnum in my waistline. You
know, I was, we were cowboys, man. We,
we were always armed at that time,
from 89 to probably 97 or 98,
we were holding pistols on our hip,
like cowboys.
And you know, he knew that. So yes. But he
would ask me to go to the gigs, you know,
t, you know, double as his body
guard. I was in his body guard,
but I was his bodyguard. Do you know
what I mean? Right, right. And, um,
I'd see the way he handled it
and let's see the way, you know,
people crowded around him
and, and uh, you know,
so I learned how to deal
with it. Watching, you know,
how he would do it in a negative way
or a positive way. Cause you know,
use some times, embrace the crowds.
Sometimes it's like fuck off of me.
You know, like a lot a lot of
artists are, you know, and uh,
that sort of prepared me so that when,
you know, we got an RF lane, you know,
I knew how to sort of deal with it and
I, you know, was always courteous and,
and cool and respectful and never the
guy that is like, Nah man, fuck that.
Get out of here. Cause I see it in some
of my homies were like that, you know,
and I didn't, I hated the feeling
that when the fans would walk away,
just totally fucking wind out of
their sails and shit like that.
Now they don't like this
artist ever again. You know?
And I saw that and I never wanted to have
anyone walk away with that experience.
So I always embraced it, even when it
was a pain in the ass, you know? So.